I'm Shane Harris with the Alabama
Cooperative Extension system today is
the first day of spring a lot of folks
are eager to get outside and do a little
yard work maybe even get those spring
gardens ready to go been a long winter
been a wet winter but there's lots of
things to be done one thing is to get
rid of the weeds get the garden ready
get it ready to be planted maybe take a
saw test things like that let's talk
about a few things that you can do this
time of year the traditional method of
getting the spring garden ready each
year is to get the tractor out and disc
and plow the garden I always called this
the pop ball method because pawpaw was
always ready to get out and use his
tractor for the first time each spring
disking and plowing turns the weeds over
prepares the seed bed against the garden
and feel ready to plant in the spring
time be sure to check the moisture
content you don't want to disc when it's
too wet as it will cause heavy clods
although labor some ham removal is
another method of removing the weeds
from the spring garden this can take a
lot of time and effort but the chore
must be done one common method for of
controlling weeds in the garden is use
of herbicides purposes containing
glyphosate which is a non-selective
herbicide is commonly used to prepare
the garden as well as control weeds if
since herbicides are used it may take
two weeks for symptoms to show as well
as control to take place also do not
plant immediately allow a few weeks
after the Keele to plant the seeds point
in corporate transplants in addition to
controlling the weeds it's a good idea
to take a soil test if you've not done
one in the last three years having a
soil test little file is a very valuable
because it's going to tell you where
your pH Sol is where your fertility
level is and what nutrients you may need
to add a Soltis will check the peas
level look
and tell you if you need to add lime or
not to raise the pH up to six or six and
a half which is ideal for vegetable
gardening many summers problems
including blossom end rot are related to
low pH or high pH so that's one way to
correct those but also check to tell you
what your fertility level is and what
nutrients you need to add or in case you
may not need any at all for that
particular year salt test kits and boxes
are available at your local 10 Extension
office and locate also a many of your
local garden centers for seven dollars
you can test your soul to see exactly
what you need this spring good luck in
your spring garden this year I hope you
have a wonderful harvest for more
information contact the local County
Extension Office or visit us online at
ACC D you go gardening